- Hello everybody, I'm Maurice Samuels
and I wanna welcome you.
I'm the director of the Yale program
for the Study of Antisemitism,
and I wanna welcome you here today.
Before we get started, I just
want to advertise our talk
for next week, where
I'll be in conversation
with Ken Stern about
antisemitism after October 7th.
So we'll be trying to address
the current situation.
Today, though we're gonna
go backwards in time
to maybe a somewhat easier
time, although maybe not,
but with a real expert
who's also an old friend, Bryan Cheyette.
He's Professor Emeritus of
Modern Literature and Culture
at the University of Reading
and a research fellow at the
University of Southampton.
Bryan has published or edited
an astonishing 11 books.
Four of his early publications
were on antisemitism
as a form of what he
calls Semitic discourse.
These include "Constructions of The Jew
in English Literature
and Society" from 1995
and "Between Race And Culture" from 1996.
His recent work
connects the history of
antisemitism with colonialism
and anti-Black racism in, for example,
"Diasporas of the Mind",
published by Yale
University Press in 2014,
and "Ghetto, A Very Short Introduction"
published by Oxford
University Press in 2020.
He's currently writing
a comparative history
of testimony from slave
narratives to refugee stories.
The talk that he'll give today is called
Edwardian Popular Culture
and Everyday Antisemitism,
and is part of an unpublished
article on the long history
of social media and antisemitism.
So before I hand it over
to Bryan, just a word about
how things will work today.
We've disabled the chat function,
but you can ask questions
using the Q and A function
at the bottom of your screen.
And then after Bryan finishes,
I will filter those questions to him.
So he plans to talk for about 40 minutes
and then we'll have 20
minutes for discussion.
So please submit your questions
using the Q and A function.
And you can submit them at any time,
including during the talk.
So without further ado, I
will hand it over to Bryan.
- Thank you so, so much,
Maury, for that very generous
and kind introduction.
And it's great to be in touch again.
The last time I spoke at Yale,
I think I flew in, had a car,
gave my talk and flew
out a day or two later.
So this is much greener, much greener.
And thanks so much, Inessa,
for organizing this seminar.
And I'm gonna now screen share
to show you all the Inessa's
absolutely fantastic poster.
Okay, so you can see the poster here,
which I'll come back to, the
Spider Cat, the Spider Cat.
Also just to say that
this is part of a work
that speaks to the long
history of antisemitism
on new media.
So I can actually speak
about the present day as well
in terms of my lecture.
But let's, first of all,
let's start with the history
and then we'll see where we end up.
So "The age of trash
triumphant," you can see,
even though this is a
phrase, a wonderful phrase
that Henry James' narrator uses
in an 1894 story, "The Next Time",
he thought of the present day
as the age of trash triumphant.
That is his present day, not ours,
but of course it could also apply to ours.
And as we'll see though,
1894, when the story was was
written, it's significant
as it was the year when the
expensive three volume novel,
and you can see an example
here of a three volume novel,
Wilkie Collins's novel we can see.
Oh, I must not keep touching...
There.
There it is, in three volumes.
Now the three volume novel
was incredibly expensive.
Only libraries and the very
wealthy could afford this.
And it came to an end in 1894
when affordable one volume paperbacks
or yellowbacks or penny
dreadfuls were widely produced.
This enabled bestselling novelists,
and we're looking at four
prominent examples today,
including James' close
friend George Du Maurier
who with a group ended the
library edition of the novel,
which prevented authors
from profiting fully
from their work.
All of the authors that we're looking at
gained a mass readership of many millions,
and all had multiple films
and theatrical productions
based on their work
and all kinds of other spinoffs as well.
Their representations of Jews
varied from, as we'll see,
antisemitism to philosemitism
and all points in between,
what I call a Semitic discourse.
The novel was, in the early
years of the 20th century,
the most accessible art form,
and sold in even larger numbers in America
where they were even
more cheaply produced.
And you will see that this
is a transatlantic story.
And I kind of regret regret
having Edwardian in the title
because really what we're talking about
is the end of the 19th,
beginning of the 20th century.
But in both Britain and America.
The growth of bestselling fiction
not only changed the publishing industry
and the modes of book
distribution, marketing,
and authorial entrepreneurship,
but culture itself.
For the first time the novel was portable,
easily accessible,
serialized in sensationalist
newspapers, as I've said,
and promoted by literary agents
and commercial publishers.
All new, the newspapers were
new, the publishers were new,
the literary agents were new as well.
Now my focus will be on the mainstreaming,
as we now call it, of
race thinking about Jews
and most other minorities
in this popular literature.
Is the medium the message?
Did this new form of cultural production
enable extreme illiberalism in the form
of exclusionary antisemitism
to reach a mass readership?
And yet I'll also ask
if this is just about
the popularization of race thinking?
Or is religious discourse
and wider social conventions
also part of the mix?
These are the kinds of questions
which I'll attempt to answer.
So we can see the four authors
here that we're looking at,
George Du Maurier, Marie
Corelli, and Guy Thorne.
I suspect George Du Maurier's
Svengali will be the one
that is best known to you.
Okay, context, everyday antisemitism.
We'll see that antisemitism has a variety
of sources in the popular novel novels,
which certainly includes race thinking
and the rise of political
antisemitism in the 1870s,
but is often framed in
religious terms as we'll see.
And refers to the debates
concerning Jewish immigration
from Eastern Europe.
Now the point I'm making here
is that the linear
history of antisemitism,
which moves historically from
religion to nation to race,
does not apply here.
Each discourse exists simultaneously.
And religion, politics, and race
were fierce realms of disputes
concerning the value or not
of Jewish citizens and Jewish refugees.
Before the first World War,
genre race thinking in the novel
was in a state of flux.
But as Lisa Moses Leff argues,
now this is on the slide, you
can see the second quote down,
there's a paradox here.
Liberal discourses were part
of the liberal public sphere,
and this certainly applies
to the novels we'll be exploring.
So I think she makes a really
important point in a book
called "Jews, Liberalism,
and Antisemitism",
that our anti-Semitism emerged,
political anti-Semitism emerged
in the liberal public sphere.
Popular fiction was a
mass cultural phenomenon
which transformed the newly
educated reading public
into book buyers, as I put here,
as opposed to book borrowers,
which they were before the 1890s.
But bestselling authors
didn't speak with one voice.
New journalism certainly included
what I've called egregious
race thinking in the context.
Also, they mainstreamed this in relation
to society and culture.
It depends whether they
were left, liberal, or not,
whether they spoke in one voice.
But novelists certainly didn't.
Even the most egregious and
conspiratorial race thinking
divided Jews into those
who would make desirable
and undesirable citizens.
And this was a phrase
used in newspapers a lot,
whether Jews were deemed
rich or poor, acculturated,
or religiously visible,
politically left or right.
The point was, are they
a good thing or not?
The novels we'll explore
are sometimes quite liberal
in their outlook, sometimes
gratuitously illiberal,
and mainly a mixture of both.
But they were part of the
public's sphere, as Leff argues.
We can see this when it comes
to what I call the banalization,
and this is the final
quote, of Christian culture.
During this period, Catholics
and Protestants were in fear
of sometimes violent disputes,
including anti-Catholic acts of parliament
to outlaw the Catholic presence
in the established church.
Jews, following historical president,
were abused by Catholics or Protestants
insofar as they were said to resemble
their religious opponents.
Within Christian theology,
Jews were after all
thought of traditionally as
devil figures, Christ killers,
as well as, through their conversion,
potential redeemers of Christ.
And these discourses,
I think especially in America,
will be quite familiar.
These ambivalent beliefs at
the heart of Semitic discourse
were particularly potent
in the popular literature,
which we'll now explore,
starting with "Trilby"
by the Anglo-French author and illustrator
George Du Maurier.
Now we can see just one
of six films on the left
here called "Svengali."
Sometimes they were called "Svengali",
sometimes they were called "Trilby".
This one stars Marian
Marsh and John Barrymore.
As prosthetic noses or
Jew-face seems to be very much
in our thoughts among many other things,
we can see John Barrymore
with his prosthetic nose.
Now "Trilby" was published in
a one volume edition in 1894
after the lending libraries
simply could not cope
with the demand for the novel.
It eventually sold two million
copies in Europe and America
and inaugurated what has been called
the age of the bestseller
after 200,000 copies were
sold in its first six months.
As can be seen on the slide,
"Trilby" mania as it was
called took a myriad of forms
and gripped America initially.
And here, as it's a fairly long quote,
and my son is forever telling me
not to put long quotes on
slides, but I'll read it.
"According to one estimate,
there were 24 dramatic
productions of the novel
playing at the same time.
One town in Florida
had a Svengali square,"
and I'm curious to see
if it's still there,
"And a Little Billie Lake
that was named after
Trilby's doomed admirer.
There were countless Trilby parties,
concerts based on the music in the novel,
along with soaps, toothpaste,"
and that's literal soaps, not soap operas,
"Toothpaste, shoes,
sweets, sausages, hams,
hearth brushes, and the
ever present felt hat,"
which is still of course the trilby hat,
part of our vocabulary.
The growth of popular
novels after "Trilby"
was characterized by literary manias
up until the first World War,
but this did not significantly
result in a moral panic
about the nature of mass
appeal until after the 1920s.
But the other side of moral certainty,
as Jonathan Friedman
has contended, you know,
in his wonderful book,
"The Temple of Culture",
the other side of moral certainty
is the exclusion of those
who do not belong.
Rivaling "Trilby" mania, the
love of the poor female victim.
And we can see here Svengali,
I think John Barrymore
trying to hypnotize Trilby
and Trilby resisting his
hypnotism in that poster,
or that film still.
But the opposite of Trilby
mania is Svengali phobia,
Svengali phobia.
And one reason for the novel's popularity
was precisely such
easily digested binaries,
culture in the form of music and beauty
versus racial exclusion.
Here we can see the wonderful image,
and I'm pretty sure it's,
George Du Maurier was an illustrator,
so it's by George Du Maurier.
And we can see this
image of the Spider Cat,
the weirdly ungainly Spider Cat.
And I think, though,
before looking a bit
more at the Spider Cat,
clearly a franchise waiting to happen,
we need to distinguish
between the text's reception
and the narrative complexity
of even bestselling novels.
The figure of Svengali is
extraordinarily ambivalent.
He's both a dazzling musical genius
and a sexually rapacious
racial interloper.
And his description removes
him from any known reality.
In other words, Semitic discourse
works on the unconscious level of fantasy,
as we can see by the quote
on the right hand side of the screen,
as well as the supposedly
more rational race science,
which we'll look at in the second quote.
But first, the phantasmagoria,
the fantasy surrounding Svengali.
"It's as if you were
a weirdly ungainly cat
and most unclean."
Of course, the idea of the Dirty Jew
and Marie Corelli, we'll see,
uses this awful phrase quite a lot.
"A sticky, haunting, long,
lean, uncanny, black Spider Cat,
if there is such an animal
outside a bad dream."
This is very much on the level of dream,
the unconscious, fantasy.
By mesmerizing Trilby,
known as the apotheosis
of voice and virtuosity,
Svengali can enrapture his
audience to the point of,
in the novel's words, madness.
Svengali, through hypnosis,
makes Trilby's voice,
again quoting, irresistible.
It forces itself on you.
No words, no pictures
could ever do the like.
Both the audience and Trilby
are under Svengali's control.
Trilby mania, in other words,
is both a feature of the novel
and anticipates its reception.
The literary mania surrounding Trilby
may have been clear cut,
but so-called Jewish racial
difference is both rejected
and universalized by Du Maurier,
as we can see at the start of the book
concerning Svengali's British rival
for the love of Trilby, Little Billie.
And here's the main quote on
the screen which I'll now read.
And this is a quote, as I say,
from right at the beginning of the novel.
"And in Little Billie's
winning and handsome face,
there was just a faint suggestion
of some possibly very
remote Jewish ancestor,
just a tinge of that strong, sturdier,
repressible, indomitable, indelible blood,
which is not meant to be taken pure.
Fortunately for the world
and especially for ourselves,
most of us have in our veins
at least a minimum of that precious fluid,
whether we know it or show it or not."
Now the transgressive ambiguities
concerning the preciousness
of Svengali's Jewish blood
are immensely troubling, I think.
Everyone has some of this Semitic blood,
according to the narrator, in
their veins, but not too much.
The novel, for all its concerns
about the virtue of Trilby,
is on the side of impurity
as indelible blood is not
meant to be taken pure.
And yet the all important boundary
between racial and sexual
purity and impurity
is impossible to locate.
What could at least a
minimum of Svengali's blood
possibly mean?
Trilby is the product of Svengali's
pure blooded sexual voraciousness
and artistic virtuosity,
and is shaped by these unleashed desires.
I've seen in the novel's
stupendous reception
such desires are notoriously
difficult to control
and could both denigrate Svengali
as well as idolize Trilby.
Okay, our next novel.
And here we're going
to look at one spectrum
of the Semitic discourse,
the philosemitic spectrum.
Trilby unleashed a veritable
slew of contradictory
and free floating Jewish representations,
which soon transforms
Svengali from the exception
or the exceptional figure to the rule.
For the rest of my talk,
and I'm assuming I've got time,
and I want to focus on three
bestselling authors who,
unlike Du Maurier,
combined race and culture
with Christianity.
And as I say, religious
discourse is just as important
as political and national
discourses at the time
and in the text that I'm reading.
Now, I'm going to start
with, as I've said,
the philosemitic Hall Caine,
or at least he was regarded as such
by the Chief Rabbi, Israel Zangwill,
and the Jewish Maccabean Club.
This was a club of professionals,
intellectuals, artists
who made Caine
their one and only
non-Jewish honorary member.
And Caine spoke at the club,
and I'll talk about one of
his lectures in a minute.
Caine's novels sold
more than anyone else's,
with lifetime sales of about 10 million.
His declaration of prophetic
wisdom fed into the fiction,
which laid claim to spiritual
quasi Christian humanism.
And we can see an example
of this in the first quote
on the slide.
We can also see the extent
with the caricature here of of Caine,
the extent to which
writers became celebrities,
their name, as they are
today with celebrity authors,
above the title.
And we can see on the
right hand image here
the way that novels were marketed
very cleverly and subtly.
So Caine's philosemitism, the first quote.
"Palestine is a Jewish commonwealth
protected by all the powers
and perhaps also partly
controlled by them.
And if this is not the millennium
the Jewish people have
looked for and prayed for,
it may be a step in that
general progress of the world,
which is binding all parts
and all peoples together."
And you can see here how he moves from
religious ways of thinking, millennium,
to humanism, binding all peoples together.
Many of these novels' plot
lines were based on the Bible,
and he was one of numerous
authors at the time
who wrote "A Life Of Christ".
I'm not sure there's a book
on the numbers of books
on the life of Christ at the time,
but I think that would
be an interesting topic.
He was a firm supporter of Zionism,
as we can see from this quote.
And also Zangwill's Jewish territorialism.
And visited Jews in the Pale of Settlement
on behalf of Anglo (indistinct)
and wrote up his experiences
in "The London Times".
In a series of articles he
distinguished between those
who traveled legitimately to the West
and those whom he called euphemistically
illegitimate refugees,
that sound familiar?
Or quote, independent immigrants.
That even philosemitism distinguished
between desirable and undesirable Jews
can be seen in the second quote,
which contended, on the slide,
which contended that Jewish persecution
was partly in response
to Jewish self-separation
or ghettoization.
So this is the shorter quote on the slide.
"May I dare to say that
it would be well if Jews
came oftener into the light
and free air of the world
that is common to all men."
Here he was reflecting
contemporary accounts
of anti-Semitism,
which blamed Jews and Judaism
for their persecution.
Now one reason that
Caine was so successful
is that he encouraged a view of his work
that associated ethical
thinking with novel writing.
By placing his self-proclaimed
prophetic imagination
at the heart of his fiction,
Caine replaced the uncertainties
concerning the established church
articulated in the so-called
Great Church Crisis of the time
with a higher form of
imagined righteousness.
His Christian humanism
meant that when it came
to the treatments of persecuted Jews,
he became a firm public opponent
of anti-immigration legislation
on the grounds that it went
against the liberal principles
which made Britain, as he
put it, "Rich and free."
Now this quote shows the extent to which
Hall Caine was well aware of
literary Jewish stereotypes.
And I think the
sophistication of this quote,
and this is the lecture that
he gave at the Maccabean Club
where he talks about
"The numerous and popular grotesque Jews
such as Fagin in Dickens' 'Oliver Twist'
and Du Maurier's Svengali."
These are all quotes from him.
In contrast, he welcomed
what he called a small group
of noble Jewish studies.
So he divided novels up crudely
into good Jews and bad Jews,
and the group of noble Jewish studies
which reflected the
sublimity of the Hebrew Bible
through the lens of Scott's "Ivanhoe",
Benjamin's Disraeli's fiction,
George Eliots's "Daniel Deronda".
And it was in this philosemitic tradition
that he wanted to write in
and wrote a novel called
"The Scapegoats" 1891,
which was to follow
these earlier precedents
and add, as he put it,
to the noble studies
by portraying a cultured heroic Jew,
a cultured heroic Jew.
And in this novel,
he compared his cosmopolitan heroic Jew
with more ghettoized Jews,
Jews who rejected him.
And also showed the process by which
his hero in "The Scapegoat"
eventually became heroic.
And that very much included
him becoming a father
to a daughter who he initially rejected.
And of course, fathers and
daughters go all the way back
to Shylock and his daughter.
Okay, I now want to compare
Hall Caine's philosemitism
with Marie Corelli's antisemitism.
Marie Corelli also
associated ethical thinking
with her novels, but she
took entirely the opposite
perspective of her archrival Hall Caine,
and actively opposed the
immigrants of Jews into Britain
and was one of the most
prominent supporters
of the 45,000 strong
British Brothers League
who campaigned for
anti-immigrant legislation,
the first such act of its kind,
which was eventually passed in 1905.
A favorite of Queen Victoria's
and Winston Churchill's,
Corelli was the most popular
woman writer of her age,
who most notably, as I say,
rejected liberal verities
in the name of her
bespoke Christian values.
Her fame at its height resulted
in her best known novels.
She published 30 in all,
selling more than a
100,000 copies annually,
with overall sales close to
the 10 million of Hall Caine.
Whereas Caine was on the side
of tolerant British liberal conventions,
as seen in his opposition to
anti-immigrant legislation,
Corelli, his antithesis,
was distinctly illiberal when it came to
what she called the spirit of the Jew.
And she talked about the spirit of the Jew
in an essay which I'll now read a chunk of
called "Society and Sunday".
The phrase "The spirit of the Jew"
I think was very much
in the air at the time.
In terms of Otto Weininger's,
the translation of "Sex and Character",
which was another popular text
which talked about the spirit of the age,
meaning that modernity is Jewish.
And there's been a lot
of work on Weininger.
I think the point that I want to make,
and I haven't had time
to make it in this talk,
is that there's all kinds of connections.
And I'll make a few later on.
I've already talked about
James and Du Maurier,
there's a lot more to be said about that.
We'll look at TS Elliot.
I haven't time to look at
Joyce or Virginia Woolf
or Dorothy Richardson or Djuna Barnes.
But the links between
high and low culture,
the popular and the literary,
is very much a subject
that needs exploring.
But here we just have the
gutter, Marie Corelli.
And I'll read now from
"Society and Sunday".
"According to the latest
views publicly expressed
by both Christians and un-Christian
clerics, it would appear
that 20th century society
is not one with Sunday.
It no longer keeps the seventh day holy.
It reads its up to date
books and magazines
and says the Sabbath is
a Jewish institution.
And though the spirit of the Jew pervades
my whole constitution and composition,"
and here she's speaking in the voice
of the un-Christian priests,
"And though I borrow money off the Jew
whenever I find it convenient,
there's no reason why I should follow
the Jews' religious ritual."
So we can tell her association here
between modernity and Jews,
and she takes very much an
anti-modern stance in the name
of her bespoke Christianity."
A letter of support was
read out at the rallies
of the British Brothers League
and called for branches of the BBL
to counter what she called
the constant foreign invasion
of our land and our trade interests.
Although the leaders of the
BBL, which included members
of parliament for the east end of London,
deliberately spoke of alien
rather than Jewish immigrant immigrants
to avoid charges by the
liberal party of antisemitism,
this was not the case in practice
where cries of No More Jews, Sweater,
and Go Back To Jerusalem, were
commonplace at their rallies.
Jews were also described
in east end newspapers
written by BBL's supporters
as quote, "A plague
or exacting blood money or
crucifying East London."
And as generally more demonic than human.
"Fancy using Christian
blood for their ritual",
was one not very fanciable fancy
in the east end newspapers.
Now Corelli was quite at
home with such language.
In her 1894 novel called "Barabbas",
a rewriting of the Gospels,
and quite often she wrote
as if it was another form
of the King James Bible,
she evoked the blood libel
when her character Barabbas
describes the crucifixion as quote,
"A great feast of slaughter,
the apotheosis of the Jews."
This man of Narazeth was slain to satisfy
the bloodthirstiness of the
God-elected children of Israel."
The unresolved nature of Jewish blood
in Du Maurier's "Trilby",
published in the same year,
is here settled decisively.
Now, Corelli's antisemitic perspective,
placing very much race over culture.
And whereas I think the distinction I make
is whereas Corelli
places race over culture,
Caine places culture over race.
Now, her perspective I think
is expressed most succinctly
in the 1999 title story
called "The Song of Miriam",
which concertinas together
an astonishing large number
of literary portrayals of Jewish women
following the all-encompassing
style of Du Maurier.
Based in the slums of Paris,
the story concerns the
murder of the elderly
and poverty-stricken Reuben David,
who lives with Miriam, his
14 year old granddaughter,
and is killed by his
predatory nephew Joseph Perez.
Miriam becomes a famous
Parisian opera singer
known as the Divine Miriami, who quote,
"Looked like a goddess
and sang like an angel."
Her ravishing grace had
won her the admiration
of kings and emperors, we're told.
Such preeminence on the Parisian stage
makes her a cross between
Rachel Felix and Sarah Bernhardt
as well as conjuring up the
decadent Paris in "Trilby".
But unlike Felix and Bernhardt,
Miriam stabs Reuben David
in front of her audience
with the knife that was used
to kill her cherished grandfather.
She justifies her actions
by contending brazenly
that he deserved his fate.
"It is a just vengeance," she says.
Here, race and religion is
once again indistinguishable,
as we can see from some
more quotes from the story.
And here I'll read from the slide.
And we can see an image
of one of Marie Corelli's melodramatic,
and you can hear from her style,
incredibly melodramatic
stories turned into films,
turned into theater.
Here, the new woman,
who also was very much
castigated by Marie Corelli,
is going towards the devil,
the Satan figure in the novel.
And you have a man pulling
her back in that front cover.
But let's read the quote from the story
to get a bit more of Corellian melodrama.
"A flash of large, bright, eager eyes,
a glimmer of red lips and white teeth,
and the tip of a decidedly Jewish nose
was all that could be discerned
of the 14 year old Miriam.
Joseph Perez could hardly,
and this is when he finds
himself on the stage
with Miriam, when they're
both successful opera singers,
"Joseph Perez could hardly
enunciate either words or music
so appalled was he at the
terrible look of Miriam's eyes."
It's always the eyes.
"For he saw his own dagger,
used to kill Reuben David,
glittering in her hands.
And what was far worse, he saw vengeance."
And of course, well,
vengeance we can come back to.
Summed up where we move very
much from race to religion.
"Those who follow the Mosaic
law are not bound to love
or forgive their enemies.
And the God of the Old Testament
is not the God of the New."
Okay, Guy Thorne, our
last and final novelist.
Here I just want to look
at Jewish conspiracies
in their nascent form,
before "The Protocols
of the Elders of Zion".
And there were all kinds
of conspiracies to do with
financial scandals at the time,
but they were more complicated, I think.
It's a great mistake to
read back from the Protocols
after the Russian Revolution
and the First World War.
So Guy Thorne.
Now, Corelli's shameless
race thinking encouraged
a slew of outrageously
illiberal popular writers
in the first two decades
of the 20th century.
And I'm looking at the best
known of these popular writers.
There are many, many more
that are hardly known about,
hardly known at all.
I've got a few of them,
I'm just looking at my floor covering.
Yes, here's one that no one
has written a word about.
T Kingston Clark, T Kingston
Clark, "Men versus Devils".
I bet you can guess who are
the men and who are the devils.
Lots and lots of these
such popular fiction.
I'm looking at the four
best known, bestselling,
most influential of them.
The rest are largely forgotten.
All of these popular novels
were to employ a heady mix
of immovable racial and
theological distinctions
when it came to the figure of the Jew.
But it would be wrong to assume
that they were all writing
from the same perspective,
certainly in this period.
Guy Thorne, for instance, was
a professing Anglo-Catholic
whose best known work of fiction,
"When It Was Dark, The Great Conspiracy"
is its subtitle, was described by Freud,
and we can see this from the short quote
underneath the book cover on your screen,
was described by Freud as
"An English novel of Catholic origin."
And the reason that Freud
referred to the novel
was because he was looking
at group psychology,
writing about group psychology
and was writing about the Catholic church.
And as we'll see, "When It Was Dark"
was absolutely everywhere in 1903
when Freud was doing his research.
Most bestsellers at the
time, and this is the point,
were militantly Protestants,
militantly anti-Catholic.
And this was part of the
campaign to remove Catholicism
from the established church at the time,
the Great Church Crisis.
So Guy Thorne was writing
very much against the grain.
But Thorne's pro-Catholic fiction
caught the mood of the time
by denouncing what he called,
and this is a quote from him.
He was a journalist.
In his journalism
he talked about the
curse of indifferentism,
or what we would call today secularism,
as opposed to the supreme moral
and spiritual principles he championed.
And he certainly championed
them in his novel.
"When It Was Dark" sold
half a million copies
and was the most read
novel I think in Britain.
I'm not sure that it traveled in the way
that some of the other
novels traveled to America,
because this novel was very much part
of the Great Church Crisis
in Edwardian Britain.
The great conspiracy,
and here we come to the great
conspiracy, is an attempt
to prove that Jesus's
resurrection was a hoax
by faking archeological evidence
to show that the body of Christ
was removed from its tomb
by Joseph of Arimathea.
So the resurrection was a hoax.
The novel's devilish
anti-hero, Constantine Schuabe,
and I thought a lot about his name.
Constantine obviously goes
back to the Roman Emperor,
but whether the Roman emperor
was anti-Christian or not
I think is open to debate.
Schuabe, as German language
speakers will know, is a robe.
How that signifies, I'm not quite sure.
Maybe referring to the coats
that Orthodox Jews wear.
We're not really sure.
But Constantine Schuabe
is behind this conspiracy,
and blackmails the keeper
of biblical antiquities
at the British Museum to
forge the ancient records
and place them in the Holy Land
so that they can be discovered.
Now, no wonder the Bishop of
London in Westminster Abbey,
and this is the quote that
I'll read in a minute,
and many of the popular preachers
sermonized on the novel,
which was anticipated in the novel's plot.
And now this is a familiar technique
to generate a particular response.
So the response of the
novel, as with "Trilby"
and as with so many
Hollywood films that we watch
is very much part of the plot
of the popular movie or popular novel.
So there's lots of
sermonizing in the novel,
and lots of sermonizing
once the novel's published.
And the most famous sermon,
which Freud refers to,
is by the Bishop of London
in Westminster Abbey.
"I wonder whether any of you
have read that remarkable work
of fiction entitled 'When it was Dark'.
It paints in wonderful colors
what it seems to me the world would be
if for six months,
as in the story is supposed to be the case
owing to a gigantic fraud,
the resurrection might be
supposed never to have occurred.
And you feel the darkness creep
around the world when you,"
and I won't go into details here,
but anarchy breaks out,
lots of women are abused,
it's a real dystopia that the
novel paints, a horror show.
When you see how darkness settles down
upon the human spirit
regarding the Christian
records as a fable,
then you quit with something
like adequate thanksgiving,
and thank God it is light
because of the awful
darkness when it was dark."
Now "When It Was Dark"
has been misread, I think.
And this is why I talk
about Semitic discourse,
and we can talk about
this in the questions
as opposed to simply
antisemitism or Jew hatred
or even philosemitism.
We can see that in fiction at least,
in fiction at least,
these are quite ambivalent,
ambiguous images of Jews,
even in popular fiction.
So it's been misread
as being straightforwardly
a form of Jew hatred.
And it's a complicated work.
Unlike the other fiction, perhaps,
with the notable exception
of Marie Corelli.
Even Guy Thorne's nascent
Jewish conspiracy theories
were bifurcated.
So even though we have
Jewish conspiracy theories,
they were bifurcated and
made up of good and bad Jews.
It was only after the first World War
and the Russian Revolution
that Jewish conspiracy theories
were hardened into
straightforward Jew hatred.
Now my point is that much
of what I'm discussing
is ambivalent forms of race thinking,
which I believe is akin to binary forms
of gender stereotyping.
And I'm more than happy
to expand this point
in the question and answer session.
As we can see from the
binary Jewish conspirators
in the novel.
And here I think this
is the penultimate slide
that I'll be looking at.
So I'm hoping I'm okay for time.
So first of all, we're gonna
look at Constantine Schuabe,
"Whose hair was a very dark
red, smooth, and abundant.
His features were Semitic,
but without a trait of that fullness
and sometimes coarseness
which often marks the Jew
who has come to the middle period of life.
The eyes," we come back to the
eyes, "Were large and black.
But without animation, they
were coldly, terribly aware,
with something of the
sinister and untroubled regard
one sees in a reptile's eyes."
Schuabe is a man
of enormous power and
influence, we're told,
who owns the equivalent
of the Times newspaper,
had a stellar career at Oxford,
and was about to enter politics.
He is quote, "No longer a Jew"
as he converted to Unitarianism,
which as the narrator
makes clear repeatedly
throughout the novel,
and remember, this is
written from a Catholic,
a Trinitarian perspective,
Unitarianism according to Guy Thorne
is another form of Judaism.
CS Elliot, raised as a unitarian,
also believed this of his own background.
And I can develop this in the
question and answer session.
Schuabe, throughout the novel,
even though he converted,
is called The Jew.
That is presumably why
he quote, "Hates Christ."
And maybe Unitarianism
perhaps belittles Christ,
but hating Christ, according to the novel.
And he wants to undermine
faith in Christianity
and reinforce what are called in the novel
the anti-Christian influences
which typify the age.
Now not unlike Du Maurier's, Caine's,
and Corelli's cryptic summaries,
and as we've seen, these popular
novels could take all kinds
of literary, cultural
stereotypes of the Jew
and bring them all together.
Thorne does exactly this with a vast array
of Semitic representations
in a very short space.
They begin with a red
haired, Victorian stage Jew.
And Jews with red hair, actually,
up until the 19th century,
even the end of the 19th century,
was much more common than having
the so-called Jewish nose.
So red hair was very, very
common linked to the devil,
of course, moving on chronologically
to the hypnotical
controlling eyes of Svengali,
and concluding with the
sinister Jew being categorized
as a bestial, cold-hearted
intellectual, a reptile.
Schuabe is finally defeated though,
and this is the point,
by Sir Michael Manichoe,
Sir Michael Manichoe,
who is the benign mirror image of Schuabe.
He's known as the pillar of Anglicanism,
not Unitarianism, in the English church.
So Michael Manichoe keeps
the English church going.
And at the time that included Catholicism
and the Catholic religion.
We are told that Manichoe is
a man of great natural gifts,
who has unimaginable wealth,
is a Jewish convert to Christianity
and has also entered political life,
quite literally a mirror image of Schuabe.
And I'll read the slide below here.
And we can see, Sir Michael
Manichoe, the quote below.
"He's the owner of one of
those colossal Jewish fortunes,
which, few as they are,
have such a far-reaching
influence on English life.
He employed it in such a way
which for a man in his
position was unique.
He presented a curious
spectacle to sociologists
and the world at large,
of a Jew by origin who had
become a Christian by conviction
and one of the sincerest
sons of the English church
as he understood it.
In political life Sir
Michael was a steady,
rather than a brilliant force,
steady rather than brilliant.
In English culture,
you can't be too flashy,
you can't be too showy.
So the other key thing to note here
is that Sir Michael is given
no physical description
to limit his uniquely benign presence
in contrast to his malevolent double.
And the Italian word for Manichoe
means Manichaea in English.
He's said to have a far-reaching
influence in English life,
but only for good.
His political career is steady
in contrast to the over-brained Schuabe.
We don't like intellectuals.
We don't like people to be over-brained.
Who remains intellectually
detached from the country
which he's meant to serve.
So Michael instead combines his quote,
"Jewish brain and Christian heart,"
Christian heart, which had, we're told,
already revolutionized
society nearly 2000 years ago,
2000 years ago.
Such are the binaries
which structure the novel.
One character personifies
Christ, the other, antichrist.
Only Sir Michael has the
so-called colossal Jewish fortune
and Jewish brain to defeat
Schuabe, who is known
as the most active of
God's enemies in England.
And I've just got half a page to go.
Caine's and Corelli's
fiction were also the subject
of popular sermons,
theatrical productions,
and many, many films.
But in 1903, "The Daily Mail", rightly,
a sensationalist newspaper then and now,
rightly declared Thorne
to be the most talked
about novelist in England.
Not that the novel's claim
to have generated a great
conspiracy is strictly accurate.
The conspiracy in the
novel is easily contained
and is ultimately the insane
folly of a single individual
rather than a group of individuals.
Thorne, to be sure, was
extravagant in his use
of Semitic discourse, even
describing an elderly Jewish man
as a great gray slug, which paved the way
for cruder versions of
bestial, dehumanized Jews
in the decades following.
But "When It Was Dark",
following "Trilby",
is a good deal more ambivalent
than its one-eyed reception.
The reader could choose
between the good Jew
of liberal virtue, or
the bad Jew who needs
to be banished from the national sphere,
which happens at the end of the novel.
Such binaries distinguishing
between light and dark
characterized everyday
antisemitism in a liberal context
and allowed those who engage
in race thinking about Jews
to deny that they were antisemitic,
something that happens to this day.
The liberal antisemitism
or the antisemitism of
tolerance as it's been called
continues to this day.
And I have written about it
very much in contemporary terms.
So to finish just a concluding
slide, if there's time.
Just very quickly, but we
can go over all of this
in the question and answers.
I'm talking here about
mass produced literature.
I'm asking the question,
was Marshall McLuhan right?
So is the medium the message?
I'm saying mass produced literature
mainstreams the extreme, absolutely.
And is a new medium,
but does not have a single message.
Even bestsellers are
complicated narratives.
I distinguish between liberal bifurcation,
liberal bifurcation,
which is something that's
between desirable and undesirable Jews,
which has very much become state policy.
So I'm saying this happens
at an institutional level.
It produces race thinking,
but is not the same as
illiberal exclusion.
But both, as we saw at
the beginning, coexist.
I also talk about religious, racial,
and nationalist discourses
all being intertwined.
So the linear narrative here
that looks at one at a time
I think is mistaken.
And finally, the key
thing that we must not do
is read teleologically, or to back shadow,
to read First World War
text as leading inevitably
either to the Protocols
or to antisemitic hatred.
And there I finish.
Thank you so much.
- Yeah, thank you Bryan.
That was so interesting.
And I have a bunch of questions,
and I ask people to submit them
in the question and answer period,
I mean question and answer function
at the bottom of your screen.
We don't have a lot of time,
but maybe we'll go like,
five minutes over just
to be able to talk to you
a little bit.
So first I'll take you up on your offer to
talk a little bit more about your concept
of Semitic discourse, which
is really your, I feel like,
you know, a major
contribution that you've made
to understanding this idea
that a lot of the discourse
around the Jew is racializing,
but is not necessarily negative
and not necessarily positive,
but is sort of in this in-between area.
Can you talk a little bit
more about what that concept
allows you to get at?
- Yes.
I think talking about ambivalence
or ambiguity is important
and important to this day
and important even on social media.
So I think quite often
people just simply talk about
hatred or hostility.
Now even going back to
Christianity, as I've shown,
and to the Christian
foundations of anti Judaism,
that was equally bifurcated.
So Jews who converted
were seen as a good thing,
as well as being seen as
Christ killers, antichrist.
So that bifurcation goes
very much back to the roots
of Christianity, and I
think very much feeds
into liberal culture, western
liberal democratic culture.
Obviously once you get a
more authoritarian culture,
Nazism, fascism, Stalinism,
then it's a different story.
But I'm talking here about
western liberal culture.
And I think the problem
with looking at anti-Semitism
just as a form of hatred
is that it answers its own question.
That's all that's ever
looked at in social media.
So other kinds of images of Jews
and the good-bad discourse
is simply ignored,
which seems to me, and
I've looked at social media
and the whole of Labor Party controversy
was about dividing Jews up into those
that were socialist and not.
So to me it's essential,
but for all kinds of reasons
is not followed through.
And I can make the link
with gender as well.
It's a bit like thinking
about gender only in terms
of misogyny and nothing else.
- Yeah, and that's something
that I've worked on
a little bit too, that often that split
is also a gendered split.
So especially in the French context,
which I've looked at in the 19th century,
Jewish women are idealized, sexualized
and Jewish men are demonized.
And that, you know, becomes two sides--
- Absolutely, because Jewish
women can convert, right?
They're seen as--
- And their body isn't
marked by Jewishness.
- Exactly.
And they're seen, especially
young Jewish women,
it's also ageist as well.
But yes, only Marie Corelli
can take the desirable
Jewish woman, so-called,
and turn her into something else.
- I apologize for my cold, my sniffling.
- I don't mind, I'm here. (laughing)
- Another question I
have is to what extent
this is a British story
here that you're telling,
or an Anglo-American one.
Versus, you know, let's say
the French or the German case.
So is some of this, you know,
ambiguity particularly
English in the 19th century?
- No, I really don't think so.
I think it's much more to do with the form
that the western democratic states took.
And in Germany famously,
you know, the Ostjuden was demonized,
accultured German Jews weren't.
And I think that split, in France as well.
I mean, you know, as long as you read--
- In France, it's often
mapped onto the difference,
I mean, one of the things
that defines the French case
is the mix between the Sephardic
and the Ashkenazi populations,
and that the Sephardic
Jews tend to be idealized
and the Ashkenazi Jews demonized.
- Absolutely.
I mean, I think there's all
kinds of ways of doing this.
And it does vary from national culture
to national culture, no question.
And because France
has a much more ideological
version of this, but even so,
I think the key is western European.
It's different, say,
in Russian literature.
Yeah.
- Okay, maybe last question.
This is all playing out against
the backdrop of the rise
of the Zionist movement,
and that's something that I
feel like in the Hall Caine,
it sort of came up a little bit.
But if you could just say
a little bit more about
how the Zionist movement, you
know, enters into this story.
- Well, I think certainly
the Zionist movement,
and I talk about this in "Constructions"
right at the beginning,
and in other articles.
I've written quite a lot
on antisemitism and post-colonialism.
But also divided Jews
up into good and bad.
I mean, just in a different way.
So Jews were seen as a good
thing if they thought that,
believed in a form of nationalism,
especially from the Zionist point of view,
Palestinian-centered nationalism
as opposed to Zangwill's
Jewish territorialism.
And did denigrate the diaspora.
You know, Herzl famously talked
about the ghetto mentality
and the diaspora being somehow degenerate.
And Max Nordau of course
was a number two to Herzl,
and wrote a wonderful book on degeneracy.
So I think that the
bifurcation of Jewish binaries
apply to Zionism.
Also to anti-Semites as well.
So you could be anti-Semitic
and think it was great
in "Daniel Deronda" that
Jews would leave Europe.
- Okay, last question, I'm just gonna take
just the advantage to go
a little bit over time
and just ask you, are there Jewish reviews
of these novels?
Like in "The Jewish
Chronicle" for example,
are there reviews?
Like, how were Jews reacting?
Did Zangwill himself
like, respond to some?
- Yeah, Zangwill did,
and Zangwill was in the
audience when Hall Caine spoke
at the Maccabeans,
"The Jewish Chronicle"
reviewed Hall Caine.
And they were quite sensitive
towards straightforwardly
anti-Semitic works,
so Marie Corelli and others,
but didn't pick up on the subtleties.
And didn't pick up on the fact
that Hall Caine also divided Jews up
into desirable and undesirable
in his so-called noble
philosemitic novels as well.
So it didn't pick up on that.
Anything that wasn't
simply based on hatred
was seen as a good thing.
- As a good thing, right. (laughing)
Okay, we'll take what we can get.
So, okay, on that note, I
wanna say thank you very much
for a really enriching afternoon.
Thank you to everyone who came.
And to encourage everyone,
I'm sure you're on our mailing list
and that's how you found us today.
But if you're not, please
get on our mailing list.
And next week, next Wednesday
at five, so not at four,
we have Ken Stern.
I'm gonna be in conversation with him
about our current moment
anti-Semitism after October 7th.
So thank you again to Bryan.
It was great to see you on Zoom.
I'm sorry we can't have
dinner, but another time.
So thank you very much.
- Absolutely, thank you.
Thank you very much.
- Okay, bye everybody.